salut bienvenue dans ce nouvel interview
à la table le quatrième je vais recevoir
Mike dunka qui est le chanteur de
Sinsemilia qui est aussi l'auteur de la
plupart des chansons et qui a un jour
pris en otage le JT de 13h sur France 2
non je devrais dire plutôt qu'il a
détourné enfin vous allez comprendre ça
dans l'interview évidemment on va
élargir aussi sur tout le bonheur du
monde et sur d'autres sujets qui l'a pu
vivre ces 30 dernières années
artistiques en parlant d'artistique pour
ma part je suis toujours en spectacle en
tant qu'on est actuellement vous allez
dates qui s'affiche il y a un lien dans
la description et la grande date à la
Salle Pleyel en fin d'année si vous
voulez être là ça va être une version
spéciale du show et je suis très
contente de l'accueil que vous faites à
ce format là sur la chaîne vous êtes de
plus en plus nombreux et nombreux à m'en
parler c'est très cool parce que j'adore
faire ça on a plein d'autres idées on
n'a pas le temps de faire toutes les
vidéos qu'on voudrait avec toutes les
personnes qu'on voudrait donc il est
fort possible aussi que j'en fasse un
podcast avec des épisodes en plus
n'hésitez pas à suivre ça je
l'annoncerai sur Instagram et les
réseaux comme d'habitude mais pour le
moment on va retrouver Mike d'un cas et
de la manière dont il a réussi à
détourner un JT de 13 h sur France 2
ça va mec ça va super ça va super j'ai
un truc qui est cool avec toi c'est que
même ceux qui pensent ne pas te
connaître il te connaissent au moins par
le biais de la chanson tout le bonheur
du monde
tout le bonheur du monde est-ce que tu
en as pas marre d'ailleurs d'entendre ou
de la chanter cette chanson alors non
non non j'ai de la chance il y a des
groupes qui ont eu un gros tubes avec un
morceau qui s'aiment pas oui je pense à
NTM Joey Starr déteste la fièvre je
crois que du côté de Zebda tomber la
chemise ils sont pas fan et moi j'adore
tout le meneur du monde Rikki adore tout
le monde c'est une chanson que moi j'ai
écrit pour mes filles donc j'ai un
attachement particulier à cette chanson
c'est toi qui l'a écrite oui moi j'ai
fait le texte Eric et la chante et puis
je trouve ça super classe d'avoir un une
chanson positive associée à des bons
moments de la vie des gens je sais
qu'elle est dans plein de mariages etc
donc non non non j'en ai pas marre j'en
ai pas marre c'est marrant qu'elle se
donne des mariages parce que moi j'ai
toujours aimé cette chanson et quand
j'entendais dans les mariages je me dis
mais vous avez bien écouté les paroles
c'est à dire que c'est une chanson des
spams mais c'est une chanson dure en
vrai tu vois c'est il y a pas beaucoup
de gens qui ont vraiment pris le temps
d'écouter les paroles c'est pour ça que
sur la l'album 30 ans on a fait une
version piano-voix pour remettre le
texte devant parce qu'en effet les les
couplets c'est pas joyeux c'est un père
qui s'inquiète pour le monde dans lequel
ces enfants vont grandir quand dans le
refrain tu diras vous souhaite tout le
bonheur du monde et que votre chemin
évite les bombes si tu veux faire un
truc joyeux tu mets pas spécialement bon
dans ton refroidissement
globalement je crois que ça a été par
moment oublié par les gens on me dit
super positive cette chanson je sais pas
elle est pleine d'amour oui
positif je suis pas sûr moi je t'ai
invité aujourd'hui parce que il y a 18
ans déjà c'est ouais il y a 18 tu devais
cette chanson là spécifiquement la
chanter en direct France 2 et tu as
décidé sans prévenir le journal de
chanter la chanson une chanson du même
album d'ailleurs c'est le bienvenu en
Shiraki qui est qui ont pour dire ça
critiquer la politique de Chirac qui
était au gouvernement à cette époque
j'étais président qui était Président
rien ne s'est passé comme passer ni pour
vous ni pour l'animateur mais c'est
quand même vous qui contreliez le jeu on
va y revenir aussi parce qu'il y a une
petite interview juste avant et qui pose
l'ambiance moi je mentionnais plus je
l'ai regardé c'est interview c'est
incroyable parce que tu es avec le
présentateur juste avant de devoir
chanter la chanson qui est prévue
qu'est-ce qui se passe pour toi c'est
quoi ton souvenir c'est quoi que tu
penses c'est quoi que tu ressens à ce
moment-là alors moi je sais ce qu'on va
faire je nous on a décidé la veille que
que Riki et moi qu'on allait jouer
bienvenue chez raki du coup c'est vrai
que l'interview elle prend un autre sens
quand le mec me dit bon il fut un temps
vous étiez un groupe considéré comme un
groupe engagé vous êtes quand même
vachement adouci c'est ça pour moi c'est
dans ma tête c'est bon ben ne ne
accorde-moi juste trois minutes on en
reparle dans trois minutes j'ai
conscience que ça va pas être simple
j'ai conscience que je sais qu'il y a un
seul autre personne qui était dans la
confidence j'ai le droit de le dire
maintenant que la prescription c'était
la jeune fille de la maison de disque
avec qui on bossé qui d'entrée quoi elle
a compris il m'a dit officiellement je
suis pas au courant je veux s'il te
plaît couvre moi je suis pas au courant
je tue tu m'as rien dit je veux pas le
savoir elle a d'abord essayé de me dire
non faut pas faire ça elle a compris que
pas moyen pour une fois on était en
direct la première fois de l'histoire
Insee qu'on avait fait une télé qu'on
était en direct je me souviens que sur
le coup j'ai pensé que c'était pas
préparé il était un peu méprisant dans
il était un peu il était un peu j'ai
vraiment cru durant longtemps que le
déclencheur ça avait été le fait qu'ils
disent non mais vous êtes adouci quoi
vous avez écrit chanter sur la drogue et
après vous avez tempéré un peu discours
en disant attention non non on a rien
tempéré on a clarifier la bonne
discussion d'accord on a fait un morceau
et je me suis oh là là c'est à cause de
ça c'est sûr quoi ça l'a fait briller en
fait ce qui nous a fait décidé ça c'est
on est vraiment en grosse grosse tournée
pour l'album sur lequel il y a tout le
bonheur du monde pour debout les yeux
ouverts la tournée énorme on a très peu
de jours à la maison et nous pendant des
années on faisait le choix de ne pas
jouer pour la fête de la musique parce
que nous on a commencé à la fête de la
musique en tant que groupe amateur et
dans ma tête pendant très longtemps je
disais on garde la fête de la musique
aux amateurs non on joue pas donc là
j'avais le droit à deux jours de repos à
la maison et j'étais content et coup de
fil de la maison 10 2 jours avant dans
la dernière minute France 2 ils
adorerait que vous venez pour le 13h moi
première réaction c'est absolument pas
envie je prends deux jours de pause à la
maison on a mais tu peux pas rater le
trésor si si je peux la preuve je vais
le faire on va rester on va se reposer à
la maison et en raccrochant c'est
indirect quand même juste vérifier qu'on
est d'accord que c'est indirect oui ok
bah fais on le fait et j'appelle Riquet
dans la foulée qui lui a et comme moi
non non vas-y viens on se repose on n'a
pas besoin oui mais si on y va on fait
bienvenue en chira qui guitareva ah
ouais go on y va et il y a que vous deux
du groupe qui est au courant à ce
moment-là là sur le coup c'est ma
décision j'emmènerai vu que j'emmène
Riquet à l'image bien sûr j'ai besoin de
son sa validation mais sur le genre de
truc c'est c'est ma décision et je veux
pas moi je vais en parler moi j'ai des
gens qui vont être susceptibles de me
mêlant Mike fait pas ça or moi je trouve
que ne pas le faire c'est soit j'y vais
pas soit si j'y vais faut qu'on soit
fidèle à ce qu'on est ça fait des années
qu'on essaie d'exprimer des choses au
micro etc et pour une fois on a accès à
un truc grand public et en direct on
peut pas être coupé si je le fais pas je
trahisse qu'on est depuis des années
donc j'en parle à personne pour qu'on
puisse pas me mettre la pression et
vas-y dans un sens ni dans l'autre
d'ailleurs voilà je sais ce que je veux
faire le seul qui a compris avant c'est
le chauffeur taxi parce que du coup avec
écrit qui on a pas le temps de se on l'a
jamais joué guitare voix bienvenue chez
raki du coup on répète dans taxi qui
nous emmène à France 2 elle peut faire
taxi quand on a chanson qui dit c'est
une chanson sur Chirac mais là je vous
emmène à France 2 vous allez jouer ça
sur France 2 je dirais dans une heure on
joue ça ah je prends ma pause
je peux voir ça il y a le chef
attraction nous deux et la fille de la
maison de disque à la base vous êtes
invité il y a une interview il y a que
toi qui le fait avec le présentateur
télé et il vous invite ensuite à vous
mettre sur la scène pour tenter tout le
bonheur du monde en direct en fin
d'émission tu commences à le chanter tu
t'arrêtes tu dis à Rick et parce que
tout le monde la connaissait là
attends attends en fait celui-là tout le
monde le connaît et il y a plus l'actuel
donc donne-moi chiraci et les premières
paroles de bienvenue en chiraci c'est
ici c'est chez moi tu fermes ta gueule
tu fermes ta gueule bienvenue en chiraki
c'est ça c'est en plus tu as pas choisi
la plus tendre en termes de mots ouais
parce que je trouvais à l'époque je
trouvais de la je trouve sous la
présidence Chirac alors ça c'est pas
spécialement adoucie depuis mais je
trouvais plein de choses extrêmement
violentes pour les gens Chirac c'était
quand même un mec qui avait pas Chirac
et ça clique des tonnes et des tonnes de
casseroles judiciaires tout le monde
était au courant et pour autant ce
mec-là était président Pasqua et des
postes importants tout ça on le voyait
il y avait vraiment une notion de
clairement il y a pas la même justice
pour tous c'est affiché c'est assumé je
trouve ça ultra violent donc c'est ce
que j'exprime dans le texte ici c'est
chez toi mais tu fermes ta gueule c'est
un peu le message qu'on recevait dans
haut de ok mais le morceau en lui-même
est pas insultant il est un peu
un peu cru dans les mots mais la musique
démarre qu'est-ce qui se passe par
contre sur le plateau c'est à dire que
nous on a les yeux de la caméra et on
vous voit
à ce moment alors déjà il y a un truc je
pense qu'il y a un ou deux techniciens
qu'on comprit qu'il allait se passer un
truc bizarre pendant les réglages
l'après-midi on répète évidemment que
tout le bonheur du monde et moi surtout
le bonheur du monde les mauvais en fait
on a répété bienvenue au fiati donc ça
c'est pas fait ah désolé donc on répète
tout le bonheur du monde et moi
normalement je ne chante pas sur tout le
beurre du monde mais là j'ai un micro et
je fais des cœurs tout pourri derrière
l'été juste pour obliger le mec à faire
des réglages sur ma peau aussi donc ils
ont dû se dire c'est super chelou les
cœurs du mec là c'est rare tout pourri
et quand c'est à nous de chanter il y a
en face de nous il y a plusieurs étages
en face de nous là il y a l'équipe
technique les gens qui travaillent sur
le plateau au dessus il y a des
les bureaux etc est à tous les gens qui
sortent des bureaux oui c'est une sorte
d'atriums
ils peuvent un peu se balconner pour
vous regarder et du coup on voit au
moment où on va chanter tu as tous les
gens qui sortent sur les balcons pour
voir les deux mecs qui vont chanter tout
le bonheur du monde tout le bonheur du
monde tout le monde enfin là où ça
sourit beaucoup les techniciens bossent
on bascule sur Bienvenue en chiraci et
là je vois plein de sourires ici de mec
qui tu vois je vois un peu de l'action
je veux des cartes de ma caméra les yeux
qui brillent qu'est-ce qu'ils font les
decks et à l'inverse au dessus j'entends
le
bruit d'ailleurs tu vois la fin du
morceau ça finit par un silence et juste
moi qui dit merci dans un silence
glacial merci avec la toute petite
souris merci
merci
incroyable parce que on aurait pu penser
que vous seriez coupé comme quoi c'est
c'est compliqué de couper c'est pas si
simple de couper une émission en direct
il y a déjà il y a un processus
décisionnel le temps qui se passe la
chanson est passée quoi tu vois donc
effectivement la fin elle est ultra
marquante de ce silence ta dernière
accord qui résonne et d'avoir juste
merci
oui c'est pas si simple que ça de couper
et pour autant pour la première fois je
crois que c'était la première fois de
l'histoire du journal de 13h sur le
replay la partie est coupée il coupe la
partie ça n'existe plus dès le replay
quelques heures après et là en
l'occurrence c'est une grosse erreur de
leur part parce que moi du coup il y a
plein de médias qui m'appellent c'est un
nom qui s'appelle l'effet stresand en
fait c'est pour Barbara Streisand qui
qui un jour voulait faire cacher quelque
chose qui allait sortir et donc elle a
tout fait pour que ça ne sorte pas et du
coup ça l'a mis énormément en lumière et
en fait c'est vraiment un principe qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui en psychologie
médias et en psychologie sociale si tu
si tu veux censurer quelque chose tu vas
l'éclairer dix fois plus que ce qu'il
aurait dû laisser
et là effectivement c'est tellement
inédit de se dire ils ont coupé dans un
replay ok il y a un sujet c'était quoi
il y a un sujet
donc la chanson s'arrête tu dis merci tu
es très poli il se passe quoi je veux
faire insulter comme jamais franchement
j'ai pas souvenir de mettre autant fait
insulté de fabriquer moi tous les deux
animateur l'animateur et la directrice
des des programmes des programmes et
c'est pas qu'on a peur c'est réellement
on a un TGV on n'a pas le temps de trop
traîner donc réellement on se fait
insulter tout en rangeant nos affaires
en faisant désolé on n'a pas trop le
temps du coup sa gueule de plus en plus
sur vous c'est dégueulasse que vous avez
fait vous avez pris en otage machin
c'est pas bien et je dis oui mais en
même temps si je vous avais dit on est
d'accord que jamais de la bille c'est
moi j'essaie de me défendre en disant il
y a rien de résultats c'est le journal
de 13h d'une chaîne publique deux
citoyens qui expriment une opinion ça va
le j'ai pas l'impression que la
République elle va elle va trembler
parce qu'il y a deux petits saltimbres
qui sont je me fais insulter terrible
soit disant l'Elysée a appelé dans la
foulée on se fait engueuler par l'Élysée
bah si ça à [__] l'Elysée à la raison
de les engueuler pas parce par rapport à
ce que vous avez fait mais selon moi
puisque c'est une chaîne d'État elle est
patrons de du présentateur le
présentateur quand il vous invite et qui
dit maintenant vous êtes adouci ça veut
dire qu'il a pas écouté l'album de
mémoire
c'est la chanson juste avant tout le
bonheur du monde alors c'est le nom
c'est pire que ça c'est le premier
morceau de l'album c'est l'ouverture ça
s'appelle bienvenue en chiraci et donc
tu dis en vrai
avec cette question un peu nulle qu'il
avait qu'il avait c'est à dire qu'il a
pas écouté l'album c'est à dire qu'il ne
sait pas qui l'invite donc il ne connaît
pas son risque en fait parce que à
partir du moment où tu écoutes l'album
tu dis ok c'est des gars engagés est-ce
que je prends le risque de les inviter
parce que je sais pas de quoi ils vont
parler tu vois parce que tu aurais pu
voter aussi virulent jouer tout le
bonheur du monde mais avoir une
interview très cash et beaucoup plus
énervé quoi tu vois ce que je veux dire
donc je pense que ça aurait été le cas
si jamais
enregistré l'émission oui puis mon
téléphone a explosé dans la minute enfin
de vous quitter le plateau vous
remplacez pas par les loges du coup on
récupère nos affaires en faisant
engueuler machin on prend le taxi et on
part et on me rappelle dans le taxi pour
juste pour gueuler en fait tu vois juste
engueuler donc de toute façon c'est fait
détendez-vous ça sert à rien de
m'insulter
qu'est-ce qu'il m'a dit ah ouais mais je
me souviens quand tu dis il se rendent
pas compte qu'ils invitent il y a
vraiment ça parce qu'il me dit ouais
vous auriez jamais osé faire ça sur une
grosse émission de TF1 alors je sais pas
pourquoi il me dit ça et je dis bah vous
savez monsieur nous on refuse de jouer
sur TF1 on ne joue pas sur TF1 donc la
question ce serait même pas posé
renseignez-vous sur qui vous invitez
c'était presque couru d'avance qu'on
allait pas venir et juste se contenter
de faire tout le bonheur du monde donc
toi tu ressens quoi à ce moment-là tu te
sens un peu un peu boxé ou ça te fait
marrer ou tu t'en fous bon alors ça me
fait plutôt rire je suis quand même
surpris je suis surpris de
à ce point là ça vous ça vous
panique touche énerve à ce point là et
accordez-nous le droit de d'utiliser une
chaîne publique financée en partie par
nos redevances etc pour dire des choses
et encore une fois dire des choses pas
insultantes je serais venu en disant
d'enchanter avec
ok je veux bien que garçon d'où tu te
permets d'être insultant comme ça dans
le texte de la chanson c'est pas
insultant les mots un peu durs sur les
mots que ces gens-là nous adressent dans
la chanson
tu le perçois comment est-ce que l'huile
vit comme toi ou est-ce qu'il se dit
[__] j'aurais pas dû dire oui à mon
pote ah si si moi de façon originaire
ces trucs là et et on a une telle
relation d'ultra confiance depuis qu'on
a 9 ans que est-ce qu'on est-ce que nous
on est en accord avec ce qu'on vient de
faire oui bon bah à partir de là gueule
ce que tu veux pense que tu veux nous on
est en accord avec ce qu'on a fait à
l'époque tu savais pas mais le
présentateur qui te hurle dessus c'est
le biographe officiel de Jacques Chirac
il a su comment
je pense dans les jours d'après quand
quand justement je suis contacté par
d'autres médias sur le fait que ils vous
ont censuré ils vont censuré du machin
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez c'est là
que les gens me disent ah bah non désolé
je savais pas voir ta tête la première
fois parce que tu comprends mieux le
l'extrême fureur aussi tu as eu des
fameux tégriers dans le métier tu vois
une télé oui voilà tu feras plus jamais
de télé tu es machin soit quand je
répondais vous savez on en fait déjà pas
beaucoup donc pas de souci et en
l'occurrence quelques mois après
Nagui nous invite à Taratata donc voilà
là allez faire le journal de 13h en
direct et me contenter de jouer tout le
bonheur du monde
ça aurait pas été non c'était pas
cohérent avec ça c'était pas cohérent
avec ce qu'on était donc bon pas de
regret pardon comment on réagit les
autres dans le groupe quand vous êtes
rentrés est-ce que c'était les enfants
rois qui rentraient au pays où est-ce
que il y a eu un [__] vous auriez pu
nous le dire quoi non alors touche
plutôt content un ou deux un peu plus
peur
c'est le président et c'est
sur le journal national tu vois
faut savoir qu'à l'époque on avait fait
des morceaux
contre le Front national quelques années
avant et qu'on savait eu quelques
conséquences on avait reçu des menaces
assez importantes des trucs qui nous est
comprendre que
vos chansons elles sont écoutées et
entendues et selon ce que vous dites ça
peut avoir des conséquences à la fois
content à la fois
ces classes les gars et à la fois [__]
qu'est-ce qui va nous tomber dessus il y
a il y a un acte ce que vous avez fait
mais je veux toujours savoir ce qu'il y
a pensé au ressenti la personne en me je
dis pas que c'est bien ou pas bien de le
faire tu vois je dis entre le moment de
se dire on va faire ça rique tu vas voir
ça va être incroyable et le moment de le
faire il faut quand même dépasser une
certaine peur tu as eu peur ou pas peur
c'est peut-être pas le mot mais mais oui
bonbon j'ai d'adrénaline il y a un
bontra qui a un bon mais d'ailleurs ça
s'entend dans quand on chante bienvenue
en chiraci on le chante pas très bien je
suis un peu faux je suis un peu tu sens
bien
et qu'en même temps regarde qu'est-ce
qui se passe je vois le prompteur ici où
je me dis ok pour l'instant on n'est pas
coupé enfin oui tu as j'ai d'adrénaline
oui on sait pas les malins quand même on
faisait pas les malins suffisamment
serein pour ce qu'on fait légitime on
est content de le faire on sait aussi
qu'on a pas vraiment le droit de le
faire et qu'il va falloir assumer voilà
assumer le fait de ce qu'on va faire tu
nous a parlé au tout début rapidement de
tout le bonheur du monde la chanson que
vous auriez dû chanter donc
l'inspiration c'est toi qui est assis
entre guillemets dans le canapé qui
regarde la télé à la base
j'ai un pote et très souvent on se fait
écouter des trucs etc des maquettes etc
lui il a un groupe il me fait écouter
des maquettes un morceau très très métal
sur la vengeance un truc très dur etc
donc j'écoute au milieu de 10 maquettes
et à la fin il y a 2 secondes où il dit
je te souhaite tout le bonheur du monde
et que ton cheval est mis et que ton
chemin évite les bombes
j'adore ce passage là je peux te le
prendre elle me dit bah vas-y prends
prends je prends j'ai ce truc là qui je
sais pas pourquoi ça m'a parlé ce truc
qui tourne dans ma tête quelques jours
après je suis dans mon salon il y a le
journal de 20h à la télé et là il y
avait deux filles qui ont 3 ans et un an
et demi qui joue à côté de moi et c'est
le choc entre je vous souhaite tout le
bonheur du monde et que votre chemin
évite les bombes
[__] c'est ça en fait et et les
couplets vont venir à une vitesse folle
ou là vraiment je m'adresse à elle je
sais pas quel monde on vous laissera
donc c'est le mix de tout ça bon et
après non j'ai pas je me rends pas
compte que je suis en train d'écrire un
truc qui va rester ouais très très
longtemps radio qui est encore
régulièrement radio enfin qui a eu
l'idée d'appeler le groupe Sinsemilia et
ben j'en sais rien non mais j'en sais
rien je pense que c'est en fait je
revois la scène il y a Riquet Natti et
moi dans la chambre de de chez Riquet on
doit avoir 15 saisons et on écoute un
album d'un groupe qu'on aime beaucoup
blackuru et l'album s'appelle Sinsemilia
et je sais que c'est à ce moment là dans
cette dans cette chambre que l'anneau a
dit bon on a qu'à s'appeler Sinsemilia
ah ouais cool ça a été validé en 2
minutes parce que déjà on aimait
beaucoup la Sinsemilia que je pense
qu'en écoutant l'album en question on
devait vraiment se rendre compte qu'on
aimait beaucoup la cité milliards et que
du coup décidé en trois minutes on
s'appelle Sinsemilia si j'avais su
est-ce que j'aurais choisi de nous
mettre nous-mêmes dans un cliché
réducteur du reggae tu vois je suis pas
sûr peut-être qu'on aurait réfléchi à
notre nom
et en même temps le mot en lui-même est
joli on aime le moi j'ai su que la
sincère c'était de la sincère parce que
j'écoutais Sinsemilia et que du coup tu
m'as dit mais en fait c'est une variété
de oui etc vous savez pas du tout donc
c'est pas c'est pas aussi au stand
ostentatoire que nombreuses années quand
les médiums demandaient c'est quoi je
répondais un prénom féminin jamaïcain
d'ailleurs en restant sur la thématique
quand vous avez écrit sur la chanson
douanier 007 je me rappelle la première
fois que j'ai vu le panier à
on était parti jouer pour ceux qui
savent pas chanson douanier 007 c'est
toi qui écrit un texte sur un contrôle
de douanier que vous avez eu qu'on a
vraiment vécu en partant en Suisse et tu
te mets en parole et du coup ça raconte
une vraie histoire en plus qu'un début
un milieu une fin et même un climax un
tour de magie à la fin tu vois c'est
c'est et du coup elle a un grand succès
aussi pour ceux qui vous écoutent est-ce
que tu pensais qu'en écrivant ça
décrivais aussi le fait que durant 30
ans à chaque fois que vous alliez
rencontrer les douaniers ils allaient
vous faire c'est vous là Sinsemilia
douanier ben venez sur le côté est-ce
que tu savais que tu avais signé ton
arènement là-dessus alors déjà ça va pas
durer 30 ans la vengeance des douaniers
mais oui elle existait déjà le début de
l'idée de je vais en faire une chanson
réellement c'est je suis tout nu devant
le douanier en me disant [__] ce soir
j'en parle sur scène on allait jouer à
Genève je mets ce soir j'en repars sur
scène même je me fais un freestyle sur
scène sur ce qu'on est en train de vivre
en fait c'est ta manière de l'accepter
en temps réel de te dire je vais faire
ma vengeance ouais ça peut m'avance
voilà c'est ok là je peux rien dire je
suis tout nu devant le douanier si
j'ouvre ma gueule et j'ai plutôt une
grande gueule si j'ouvre ma gueule on
passe jamais la frontière et on fait pas
le concert du soir donc je vais fermer
ma gueule après pour ceux qui
connaissent la chanson pour ceux qui
connaissent pas en fait ils s'avère
qu'on a passé de nombreuses heures à la
douane qu'on a tous fini tout nu et que
pourtant le douanier n'a rien trouvé et
que un quart d'heure après dans le
camion
on célébrait à la santé du douanier bon
après je vous laisse découvrir le
commandant du pourquoi de du tour de
magie dont tu parles en effet pour faire
une chanson mais en plus l'histoire elle
est classe à raconter et en fait je
pense qu'on aurait pu s'en tirer avec
les douaniers français sauf qu'on a fait
un clip et que le clip il est plutôt
sympa M6 a trouvé le clip super sympa ok
les gars on va vous mettre en clip des
clips pendant 2 semaines le matin OK et
visiblement les douaniers français ils
regardent M6 le matin oui c'est ça c'est
parce que la musique
confidentielle un vrai succès à l'époque
ça perdait pas toutes les couches de la
population encore auprès de auprès de
gens que ça choquait pas du tout notre
discours sur les douaniers le clip ça
touche le grand public et du coup il y a
spécialement deux été de suite ou quand
dans notre tournée des festivals on
arrivait très régulièrement avec la
douane volante qui nous attendait devant
la programmation
on va se mettre là mais c'était pire que
ça qui nous attendait ils attendaient le
tourbus tac ok il nous a galéré à un
moment qui a pris des en fait
après-demain vous êtes à Toulouse ouais
ben vous saluerez nos collègues parce
qu'il vous attendent aussi bonne tournée
les gars
ça a été un peu long attention il y a
plein de douaniers qui sont super cool
pour de vrai je dis ça c'est pas des
magots dire ça la chanson elle est sur
le fait que là le douanier Suisse était
abusé dans son côté voilà et qu'on a on
est tombé sur quelques douaniers abusé
on a aussi croisé plein de douaniers
très cool après il y a eu tout le
bonheur du monde et ça apaisé tout ça
d'un seul coup c'était ok on a le choix
entre les emmerder en contrôle ou leur
demander des autographes on va demander
des autographes c'est un vrai tout le
bonheur du monde a vraiment apaisé le
truc imagine que peut-être dans le tas
dans dans la catégorie des douaniers pas
cool qui si je comprends était
minoritaire d'avoir rencontré quand même
franchement oui il y en a un qui
peut-être détesté et peut-être que son
fils ou sa fille s'est marié avec tout
le bonheur du monde
donc 30 ans de tournée au final toutes
ces chansons vous avez fait tous les
enides de France et vous avez décidé
avec Riquet de jouer dans ce qui n'est
pas une salle ça s'appelle des jardins
les appartements même parfois de votre
public
je spoil pas doux est venu cette idée
c'est un bien incroyable de dire on va
jouer chez les gens dans leurs apparts
dans leur jardin il se passe quoi il y a
beaucoup de gens qui pensent que c'est
lié au covid et en fait non on avait
commencé avant avec Rick et ça fait des
années que parallèlement à on adore
l'aventure avec parallèlement on a
toujours cherché à faire des trucs un
peu à gauche à droite comme ça et là
puis les années place plus on a envie de
faire des trucs nouveau moi je me dis tu
as peut-être pas encore enfin c'est sûr
j'ai pas 30 ans de plus à faire dans la
musique donc profite fait des trucs que
tu as envie de faire pour pas très bien
plus tard dans la merde j'aurais dû
faire ça [__] si on allait jouer chez
les gens quand je lui en ai parlé la
première fois il m'a regardé chez les
gens c'est à dire c'est les gens c'est
d'ailleurs rostson on rentre on joue
ouais mais les micros machin non non
mais pas de micro ta guitare toi moi
assis dans le canapé on joue chez les
gens bon je savais pas si ça marcherait
j'ai mis un petit message sur mon
facebook en disant bah avec qui on
étudie la possibilité de venir jouer
chez les gens bon ça a plu
on a repris les tournées on a fêté notre
30 ans etc c'est tous ces trucs là sont
aussi des trucs qu'on vit en parallèle à
Sinsemilia en plus et donc effectivement
suite à tout ça aujourd'hui vos
produisez donc Rick et toi dans des
théâtres des cafés théâtres de France
avec un spectacle qui s'appelle
souvenirs de saltimbanque est-ce que tu
peux d'abord nous parler de ce spectacle
on se marre
voilà on se barre
osmar et on prend du plaisir
il y a évidemment de la musique mais
c'est pas un concert mais il y a de la
musique qui nous sert de fil conducteur
tout le long du spectacle on va se
promener dans les pleins de souvenirs de
Sinsemilia les souvenirs appelés plus
fous ils sont bien fous parce que même
si tu connais pas Sinsemilia je sais
qu'on t'emmène dans dans notre histoire
on l'a vu avec plein de gens qui
venaient un peu et qu'on emmène donc on
va chanter on va rire on va vous
raconter des histoires on va faire des
conneries on va écrire une chanson
ensemble on va on va faire un quiz pour
voir si vous êtes bon à découvrir les
ragots on va faire plein de conneries le
seul but c'est que les gens repartent
avec le sourire du coup chanter et
parler aux gens c'est pareil ou pas non
c'est pas pareil c'est beaucoup plus
intime de parler c'est bizarre de dire
ça mais parce que bien sûr que c'est un
team de chanter selon ce que tu chantes
mais c'est pas parler c'est faire rire
les gens enfin raconter des choses
vraies et les faire rire c'est un
plaisir incroyable c'est un plaisir
incroyable j'ai vécu pendant 30 ans le
fait de chanter faire chanter les gens
les faire danser et c'est aussi un
plaisir incroyable j'aurais pas parié
qu'à 50 ans on aurait une nouvelle
aventure ou comme tu disais on est dans
les lieux labellisés humour et que
j'entendrai des salles éclater de rire
moi il y a j'ai un énorme respect pour
Rick et toi c'est-à-dire mec qui ont 30
ans de carrière des disques d'or des
Olympiens vous avez tout vécu et à 50
ans tu te dis pas ils vont se mettre
dans la galère aller faire les
caféthéâtres que nous humoristes on fait
dans nos débuts tu vois et encore vous
gravissez des échelons très très vite tu
vois mais mais incroyable de se dire et
en plus avec le soir je vous ai jamais
vu vous plaindre de faire une date alors
que vous vous faites tous les formats
vous essayez tout ça c'est incroyable en
fait alors je te remercie mais il y a un
truc qui est très différent c'est petit
lieu quand tu les fais vraiment par
choix comme c'est notre cas c'est
vachement plus facile à faire que quand
tu les fais en espérant que ça
débouchera un jour sur autre chose nous
c'est un vrai choix d'être dans des
petits lieux intimistes etc comme tu le
dis on a rempli les plus grandes salles
de France j'ai une dizaine de disque
d'or etc tout ça mon ego il a été
suffisamment flatté donc tout ce qu'on
fait maintenant j'ai pas de question de
ni d'ego c'est vraiment qu'est-ce qu'on
a envie de faire qu'est-ce qui va nous
faire marrer ouais on est trois dans un
Duster et on parcourt la France pour je
donne des petits lieux et ça nous éclate
tu as des petits lieux des petits lieux
le 8 avril vous êtes quand même à
l'Européen oui celle de Paris si vous
voulez venir il y a un lien dans la
description c'est 350 places ça va être
pour pour une idée qu'à germer dans des
jardins de personnes il y avait dit 10
personnes qui vous écoutent
quand même
chaque jour dans ce qu'on vit on se dit
que c'est fou et vous les verrez en
tournée ou à l'Européen le 8 avril
moi j'y serai ça peut être très cool
merci Mike merci c'était juste
passionnant et si vous dites que vous
auriez pu écouter ça longtemps et ben
allez les voir en spectacle allez voir
le projet souvenir de saltimbanque de
Mike et Riquet si vous avez l'occasion
d'être à Paris le 8 avril ça va être à
l'Européen vraiment le spectacle est
très bien je ne l'ai vu plein de fois si
vous connaissez sinsey vous allez kiffer
si vous connaissez pas Sinsemilia vous
allez kiffer aussi vous êtes pas prêt
pour toutes les anecdotes là c'est rien
ce que vous avez eu aujourd'hui donc je
vous mets les liens dans la description
de leur tourner et précisément aussi de
l'Européen merci d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo abonnez-vous à très bientôt Ciao